[Music]
now welcome to the intermediate class
intermediate class my name is Grand
Master ester Sarawak
all right maybe not okay in 1950 oh wait
a minute
no I'm been Feingold so we'll stick to
the 80s which this game is from this
game is from my first US Open in 1982
who knows where that was anyone nothing
you should it was in st. Paul Minnesota
for some reason in fact if you could see
this up here if you could see that up
there that's what it says yeah I always
wondered since Mississauga and Rana both
have more people why those are the twin
cities but okay we're off the subject
today's lecture is gonna be about
attacking and some people when they're
attacking or they think they're
attacking which is more likely than
they're actually attacking as soon as
they do something good like when upon
and then they stop and they're like oh
how could I trade all the pieces off and
give my advantage away why do you guys
talk like that but yeah these are games
that are generally mine possibly all
mine where I was attacking and I kept
attacking occasionally sacrificing
material which I don't like to do well
in this position we can see that White's
castled and black has not also White's a
piece ahead hooray so if black trades
Queens then white SAP he said so what
move did black play easy question don't
want to be down a piece Queen takes
Knight don't don't want to be down a
piece I pushed the forward arrow that
didn't help there we go okay so now what
is the material situation who's ahead
who's behind or both
anyone who's upon down whites upon down
and as compensation
not only does white have a castled King
and black dozen
but this Bishop on f8 is very suspicious
and what White has the two bishops so
white has compensation for his pawn -
and now white makes the most obvious
move even to the most dim-witted
individual with an advanced degree in
hyperbolic topology you would see this
move anyone guess the closer if you
can't see what is white play in this
position to continue the attack or start
it this should be fine check quiet but
deadly because it was said quietly so
okay so Black has two moves that are
legal Knight d7 which isn't very good so
King d8 okay now one thing I tell my
students if I want them to win if I
don't like my students like like Owen
for example then I would say the
opposite but if I like my student I want
them to win when they have an attack I
tell them to use all their pieces like
the famous great player from the 1800's
Paul Morphy the Paul Morphy when he
attacked he used all of his pieces which
gave him a greater chance of success
while White's only attacking with two
pieces so how do we bring another one
into the attack noddings not the right
answer
how does white get more pieces attacking
it develops a good start attack the
night with the bishop
oh you mean Bishop g5 I think the ninth
defended three times so I don't know if
that attacks the night that's ah so you
want to play Bishop g5 to remove the
defender of d7 and now you're making
some sense not much but some right okay
so let's play Bishop to g5 okay now in
your professional opinions
does black want to trade Queens or leave
Queens on the board no opinion
who's the Supreme Court justice who
never talks what's his name ah Souter
that's terrible he talks like once every
12 years he's known for that yeah yeah
Thomas no opinion nobody yeah
is that your favorite justice iris
Thomas no absolutely not
English don't you a newspaper reporter
say the English that's correct so if one
site doesn't want to trade pieces the
other side does so since we have a
threat this ship takes a night and then
Queen d7 mate black would either play
Queen b6 or Queen to e4 and then white
would have to somehow not trade I think
Queen b6 because that Forks to pieces
also yeah so Bishop g5 is a good idea
but it's too slow and somebody had the
right idea but they were not speaking
English so so what should why do get
more pieces out and we actually stopped
Queen b6 because Queen b6 virtually
forces a queen trade because I'm gonna
take your queen or take your bishop and
then if you trade Queens then what why
is this game in my class it's an
attacking game what it's not endgame
technique that's next week anyone
Bueller yes Bishop e3 BAM
you recognize this game's fans know this
is a game I played when I was 13
although I may have been 12 when I was
12 yeah I was 12 actually
hey this games in a book there was a
book on this tournament which makes no
sense but it's true us it's one of the
weakest if not the weakest US Open of
all time and 83 the next year was
probably the strongest and it was the
most players 83 US Open in Pasadena
California had about 860 players and it
had about 20 GM's this one had two GM's
and when I say GM's I'm being nice was
biz guy or insult Asst and lob this guy
wasn't this guy or anymore and Soltis
was never assaulted so I mean yeah and
so I couldn't win the tournament because
my rating was 2,000 so I helped make it
weak okay so my opponent wanted to trade
Queens so he played that would hang the
Queen to Bishop takes yeah I would well
not a piece they would Danks of them
yeah well even worse so how does black
attempt to trade Queens cuz that Queen
on e6 is ominous
way louder like you're like you're like
me loud queenie for or queen g4 that's
correct
you play queenie for queen g4 is the
same that's good so now did I trade
Queens the little girl is correct
like on Simpsons okay so if we trade
Queens again this is the wrong class on
the other hand it's hard not to trade
queens because the only move I could
make would be like Queen f7 or Queen h3
terrible not impressed at all with those
moves okay so now is the part of the
lecture where you sacrifice all your
pieces for checkmate your favorite part
of the lecture I'm sure I'll call in a
random student Joe what did white do in
this position and Joe's never seen this
game he's like what calling on me
now while he's thinking if we can call
it that correct right now you may wonder
how do you sacrifice a piece I know
whether you're winning well the answer
is you're usually not so stop doing that
okay you guys wonder enough pieces you
have to sacrifice them and add to it but
when you calculate some attacking move
like this should be six check it's
always good when your opponent can't
move anything like this Bishop on f8
this rook on h8 they're not helping
black defend so even though I'm down a
piece I'm virtually up a look because
all my pieces are attacking and luckily
I have this open C file
there's no pawns on it so this is a very
easy calculation he has to take
otherwise he has to resigns no other
legal moves
I take he has one legal move even Ken
West can see it see a came to c8 now we
check him again rook c1 Shaq blocking
was a queen isn't dangerous for white so
King to b8 and now there's more than one
way to win but I played the simplest I
threatened made on b7 how do you
threaten made on b7 you rook c7
threatens me but it's not what I did
it does win then black would play rook
a7 and then white would win in two or
three more moves I did bishop c6 and now
rook a7 is risky because of Queen d8
made the King needs this escape square
now my opponent wasn't very happy now of
course when I played Bishop e6 I saw
this position but even if I hadn't I
mean this is just terrible
akari's not impressed at all with blacks
position rook on h8 trap bishop on f8
and all of whites pieces are attacking
the rook the bishop I have another look
in case I play like Joe example Joe
wanted to play rook c7 and then if for
example Rick a7 Joe was planning rook C
one threatening rook c8 mate
also good also good would be Bishop to
c6 here also good the point is
everything is winning because my
opponents pieces aren't really defending
they're just sitting there on the back
row and if I use all of my pieces to
attack and my opponent uses very few to
defend I'm likely to be correct not
withstanding just calculating to me
calculating the mates also good but if
you can't calculate all the way to mate
and you realize you have more pieces
than your opponent then you should win
anyway okay the next game was also
played a thousand years ago in a galaxy
far far away
now this was no more suspicious games
and I hate to admit this but if you
thought you played badly and you do - I
played worse not not really and I mean
what when I was rated 23 2,400 I gave it
imagine then when I was rated 23 2,400
all my games were suspicious I would
play for tricks you know I was a kid so
tricks are for kids and they'd work
sometimes and then I would win
and then when they didn't work I'd have
a losing position I'd keep playing for
tricks and eventually I would win and
then I'd be like shaking my head like I
was awful okay although I started to
like it because I'd be losing a lot and
I'd win but I played for a lot of tricks
back then even here I'm over 2,400 but
I'm still worse against a player much
lower rated than I am and this reminds
me a lot of which player in the US
Junior Championship Spencer very good I
could remember his name that's why I
called on you yeah Luke Harmon Vlade
very suspicious every game - 10 he
should resign but he wins every game
anyway because he keeps making threats
and then eventually his opponents fail
okay now in this position I'm down my
usual one pawn and my opponent wants to
trade Queens but I don't wanna do that
so I played the obvious move rook b7
check and my opponent has five legal
moves that right if Ken West disagrees I
know I'm right I see five am i right Ken
okay so that I know I'm right it's fine
right it has to be fine because ken
didn't agree if you agree I was no way
does canvas
I think hem mrs. King f6 oh you missed
the Queen key block here and here
okay that wasn't just these are good
games to play okay well obviously my
pawns didn't block with the Queen
because you know ridiculous King f6 also
is not good although might be better
than what he played no okay so so we're
going to vote because voting is fun and
there's actually two positions in this
in these group of positions on attacking
that I want to show you where we're not
necessarily finding the winning attack
we're finding the proper defense
occasionally your opponent's attacking
you and you have to defend properly I'm
sure you all do that right like
Spencer's game of the Chicago open for
example were you up a rock and then you
really mad yeah you're like I will look
up for nothing and then the guy tricked
you somehow
yeah okay so you're black how do you
defend what's the right king move I'm
already giving you a hint it's not a
Queen move such a nice guy so well I'll
even give you a bigger hand it's either
King g8 or King f8 one loses immediately
and the other one like is equal or
blacks better remember if he says a move
what should you do but I could be
tricking you what piece is that what
pieces are never mind is that a Nirvana
piece but never mind
is it less dangerous
here's the answer entertain us well I'm
wondering how black should defend this
position although I was White's I'm not
wondering too much well you're you're in
check will you do it over here touch
move touch you now you gotta move your
queen for you scholastic players that's
actually important point if flag does
play Queen takes Queen check which would
happen in like half of your games and
then you say wait you can't move your
queen you're in check you still have to
move your queen touch move roll you got
to block with your queen
very
suspicious yeah yes sir hates when that
happens also Ken suggests to King g8 so
that's out of the class figured out yeah
it's not just the Queen's coming in and
killing you which Ken was afraid of but
yesterday was rated 21:40 played King g8
thinking I wasn't gonna checkmate him
with my Queen that's what he was worried
about but yes sir saw quicker than my
opponent who never saw it that rookie 7
is quite annoying because I'm not just
checkmating him but his bishop has a
little is a little iffy there on III and
now he's Queen and Bishop for attack so
he has to resign but after King f8 then
the game would still be play even though
it's 1986 we'd still be playing who do
you prefer you ask after King f8
yeah I'm white the computer's not as
scared computers like White's a little
better now nothing serious nothing
serious
yessir doesn't like blacks position
because of this rook but he still would
defend better he would play King f8
because he sees ricky 7 and that's
actually an important point
yes sir doesn't want to hear this the
biggest pterence between him and you in
chess strengths is when he's being
attacked or he has a bad position he
defends great when you guys are being
attacked I have a bad position well it's
not so good and occasionally have a bad
position in chest these things happen in
fact there was a match you guys don't
know about between short and Kasparov
and short didn't do well but short had a
lot of attacking positions in these
Knight orphe
a 6 Sicilians and he was attacking Garry
a lot and Gary had to defend a defender
defend and if he defended long enough
that Nigel started making mistakes and
Nigel had a lot of positions that I
think yessir would want and then Nigel
didn't win those games yeah he was
really good position was out the opening
with Wyatt and then he's looking to say
what happened because Kasparov not just
good at calculating and checkmating you
if you were checkmating him he would see
the way and he would prevent it so King
G at rookie 7 and yes sir was correct
white is better very good
1986 you played it you played in Dubai
olimpiadas yeah yeah King f8 that's what
that's what you like yeah it's a I
looked with my computer it suggested
Queen h3 yeah note notice the queen h7
threat risky ok h6
who you want to win this end game yeah
we don't like to have white here indeed
yeah very good I'm gonna go back in time
and see if I can win those endgame all
right now now this this game I like
because again I used all my pieces in
Morphy style okay which was actually
very popular before Gangnam style
now morphe styles out morphe style
nobody does anymore okay we could do a
morphe style in this room right now he's
videos we could do it okay so
well obviously whites attacking so okay
I'm trying to get at his King but I need
to attack with more pieces okay so I
want to attack down the H file so I can
play Queen each shape mate
but he would take it at this point so
what did I do to get more pieces to the
H file unless it's black smooth which is
likely see now I'll never know
hmm anyone yeah so what is why'd you get
to the h-file right and let's see if
it's my move now queen c8 then rook h3
correct okay so I'm ready to go on the H
file my bishop moves away Queen h8 mate
he played Knight f8 and now this was the
move in the game that I liked the most
because other than Spencer who's already
seen the game ten times most of you
haven't so it'd be very difficult to
guess White's move unless you sort of
got the theme of the lecture which is
attack and use all your pieces to attack
you Bishop takes f6 he would take with
the rook and that gives this King a
flight square I hate when that happens
yeah now if you're famous with the
famous opera game and I'm sure that you
are right spends you know Morphy versus
and the Duke very good John Wayne now in
that game Morphy my favorite movie to
game was when he played rook takes d7 so
his other rook on h1 which wasn't doing
anything could go to d1 and start doing
stuff which white piece is doing nothing
what's that the real kind anyone so I
played well we're caps one would hang my
rook sorry then my rooks not so active
any one rook e1 now now all of my pieces
are attacking all of them are doing
something now he immediately blundered
because I made a good move okay I'm
threatening his pawn on e4 which would
actually help my bishop you know help
give him the attack and now he blundered
the probably the right move is f5 and
then I could play something like Bishop
g5 not sacrificing my bishop but still
threatening Queen h8 male and the
computer engines say that I'm winning
here but not winning as much as after
his next move which was the blunder g6
what would the cargo say about their
move not impressed at all terrible
and now iris would play that wasn't so
loud but I heard you queen h8 and that's
why his pawn should be on g7 on g6 is
not as good and now unfortunately he
resigned but if he didn't resign I would
play a double check because there's no
pawn here on g7 he's in checked by to
pieces and then mate classic feingold
right and that was played in Kapaa
grande which is the suburb of what
famous French town anyone what are the
French escape
where did they leave go through the nose
see more sense wrong part of the country
yeah what are you doing terrible yes see
now you yeah with your right except for
the Marseille part right Dunkirk yeah
see there you go and Coppola is a suburb
of Dunkirk they actually a suburbs it's
amazing and this was one of the first
Coppola groans I played in the first few
when I lived in Europe and now they've
had like twenty thirty in a row and now
they got like 100 GM's each and and
didn't Alejandro go there and other
people we won't mention yeah exactly so
this is a big tournament now cop-out
lagron and this is the last round
actually on like board six so it was
good that I used all my pieces to attack
and I continued attacking so that was a
memorable game this game I like also so
in this game before this position
occurred black played 96 98 97 and his
other night did a rigmarole this night
went Knight f6 Knight d7 Knight f8 very
suspicious ok now I have the two bishops
and we have opposite side castling and I
have more space it's time to attack okay
now which white piece has nothing to do
with attacking blacks King right now
nothing it let nothing with the black
King
anyone which white piece is doing
nothing as far as the attack is
concerned the white king so I played
King deeds who got it to h6 a lot Nigel
short all right is there anyone who
wants to give a real answer you the rook
on d1 so I played afternoon h7 wrote to
g1 okay and I'm preparing what kind of
sacrifice because if sacrifice here the
ship h5 is my idea he played nine c5
making my idea work much better because
now he opens up the diagonal for my
queen so when I take then I played
Bishop takes h5 hooray and now once
again as with the other examples my
opponent's pieces are not doing a good
job defending his King now a lot of
lower rated players you know like those
of you in the audience and those of you
watching at home especially watching at
home yeah you that's right okay he knows
what I'm talking about a lot of lower
rated players when they see a sacrifice
they're like oh no I'm gonna get
checkmated so they make some random move
and now I'm upon up okay terrible when
when a guy takes your h5 pawn and then
you don't take the bishop sometimes it's
an H seven point then you're down upon
and you're getting attacked you're gonna
be at X you might as well be a piece up
okay then you might win if you don't say
my bishop then you just lose anyway okay
so he took the bishop I played the
obvious move g6 and my opponent saw that
I could sacrifice my bishop but he
missed something now my computer is very
happy to have white here because I'm
going to triple on the G file and play
f4 and my attack goes forever and ever
and ever it's not like he stops my
attack and then I'm gonna lose if he
stops my attack I just keep attacking
because as yessir pointed out i have
obviously coloured bishops
my tag goes forever and once I play f4
he could defend defend defend and the
computer still says minus five still
terrible for black but he blundered
because he miscalculated
he played Knight f6 and this gives white
actually just checkmate in a few moves
yeah he one of the moves he didn't see
so that's why he allowed it so how does
white win taking the F pawn double check
allowing pawn takes rook is a bad idea
although it's probably best although
maybe not horrible and he's in double
check because my ruck and my pawn are
attacking so he has to play King takes
f7 and now the obvious move which I'm
sure Kevin will explain you didn't have
a follow up ready
g7 now you're not your second for no
reason I mean I don't know if it still
wins doubt it computer might start doing
this why'd you give you a rook await on
g7 what if I take it I'm still confused
after rook g7 King sakes you're making
it harder for the Queen to come over
what's that Queen g6 what do you think
is that good yeah so there's one legal
move and my opponent when he did
everything he saw everything he saw this
position then he thought he was fine and
he dreaded 2,400 maybe he should learn
how to defend them what's that well it's
it's not his turn that smile I want to
make the winning move before he resigns
so what did I do
Queen h6 and he's like yeah I didn't see
that yeah now he did indeed resign that
wasn't great defense now if he plays
King g7 what does y do Ken
he did resign but if you'd play King f7
what would you do with Wyatt Queen g7
mate BAM I may not have done that
because you could make him suffer a
little
you could play queen g6 then Rick g7
that you could double rooks on the G
line that you can really make the guy
suffer okay but me yeah
notice how I'm still using all my pieces
my queen and rook on the G file and if
things don't work out I'm gonna play f4
and then he's got my Bishop to contend
with me and then that bishops coming in
terrible okay so another crushing attack
using all of the pieces my favorite okay
this game was against my favorite
opponent al Chow or as he's known in the
chess world Dog Chow because he's
dogmatic okay not cause of dog chow
because of dogmatic
okay all or as I call him foo me and
Chow because he had that thing going
right all right so yeah now every move
Chow makes makes no sense at all and I
meet him quickly I like that because I
was opponent okay now in this position
if you're a smart player you would
probably agree that black has an
isolated pawn because he does and
therefore White has a positional
advantage and I'll be working on that
pond and blockading that pawn and
attacking that pond etc and normally
that would be correct but not in this
position this position my opponent
insisted I check made him very insistent
okay now he made a quite a big move
which most of you would probably also
play he develops a piece and made a
threat the problem is he put a piece on
a worse square than it was on and he
made the threat he threatened my queen
which was this place and went to a
better square so it all worked out well
for me
he played Bishop d7 attacking my queen I
don't think my queen was had the death
grip here on the Queen side but really
wasn't really interested in that but he
forced my Queen over to f4 where I could
attack his king now his Bishop is still
attacked so he
to e7 i completed development and once
again he found the wrong plan and
normally if somebody's attacking you and
you trade pieces then they stop
attacking you because there's no pieces
left unfortunately there's a square in
blacks position that needs defense it's
currently defended and he undefended it
because he was so interested in trading
pieces
my opponent wanted to trade this bishop
for this nice Bishop which is normally
correct however that critically weakens
one important square in blacks position
anyone f5 so for example now if I wanted
to play Knight d4 to f5 he could trade
his bishop for my fantastic night but he
played Queen to b6 so I castled and then
played Bishop to b5 which not only lets
my knight get to f5 but with tempo to
make sure I can get there on the way I
can attack something so now it is Queen
on b5 I play Knight d4 his Queen moves
away and Knight f5 and as Greek
Grandmaster Vasily as Cutrone iasts
would say spans knife f5 okay now blacks
completely losing because my Knights on
f5 forever if only his bishop was still
on d7 so it's funny he he forced my
Knight to f5 with tempo and then he
forced my Queen over there by getting
rid of it
so he did everything wrong that's why
he's over 2,400 does everything wrong
okay that I tell you that my favorite
opponent so I had a funny conversation
about Chow once with Gregory Qaeda knov
okay one of the funniest guys will ever
meet and Gregory is like I don't
understand why I was 2,400 he plays so
good he thought shout should be even
higher rated that's all I got
I'd beat China every game in like 20
moves what so he yeah he's like I always
beat Chow but it's always really tough
it's like 80 moves and 9 our game plan
child played terrible okay so I guess
occasionally child play as well
occasionally doesn't and and I played
him once where he just played better
than me the whole game he was black he
had like a slight advantage and then I
moved 25 he made a nine question mark
move in resigned next move so he'll do
that too but this game he just got
outplayed okay so he played 98 although
it's hard to suggest a better move
Spence you're pretty hydrated what would
you do with black Queenie six is
probably better after Queenie six what
would you do on Queen g5 I'm just
wondering yeah exactly what's the
defense to the threat ninety seven check
yeah so you defend it even worse it
wasn't easy to do but you can see he has
you can see he has some problems here
like you're defensive we've lost
everything yeah okay
so Spencer suggested Queenie six
defending the knight a little more Queen
g5 threatening mate g6 Knight check dish
of Tanks so that didn't work out too
well right well okay so Chow play 98 ok
defense right like in the movie falling
down my wake up okay so it's confused
who saw falling down extra credit right
right defense okay good yeah queen g4
very good threatening Knight 8 6 check
winning his queen so what did he do who
I think he played Queen e6 I don't
remember was a long time ago
Queen e6 now for those of you who are
good at counting if you watch Sesame
Street the count does it a lot you'll
notice white has 3 pieces on g7 and
black has 2 so let's take on g7 a.m. now
I'm threatening everything every move is
a threat almost every member of the
discussion we had in the car every legal
move random legal who wins yeah
so all bishop moves win except bishop h8
all the bishop moves win and queen g6 97
that's not heads up d yeah that's bad D
yeah my opponent made the best defensive
move which I expected no no he defended
C that's why he's better than Qaeda Navi
expected he defends really well what no
I was thinking Arby's see notice how all
of Weis pieces are attacking still and
my rooks are saving my king from the
back rank made that a Julia suffered
okay he played the obvious defensive
move what oh they tried that the idea is
my queen is defending my bishop and it's
defending my knight so let's kick it
away from one of them now if somebody
like Spencer Feingold for example was
why didn't it was black in this position
against Grandmaster West would
Grandmaster West be up to the test and
find the best I'll wait for your
suggestion at your behest if only Kanye
was here to show all those rhymes then
you know which Kanye messes up my joke
totally with his own shock nobody got
with me terrible
okay so White's a playing win who wants
to raise their hand and suggest you nine
eight six check I would guess Queen age
six
I would guess because that Queens still
attacked on g4 careful hey when that
happens Knight takes bishop correct I've
never said that when Ken said a move
Knight takes bishop check now now the
Queen isn't defending the 90 more cuz
the knight moved away so we don't need
the Queen defend tonight and he played
Queen takes and now many moves win or at
least one does Bishop takes track
attacking his queen so if pawn takes
Queen Bishop takes Queen I'm up a ruck
and then I could win this position
terrible if only kind of was here to
shake his headedness and he played on
for a few
okay he resigned it terrible
okay last but not least and this is
quite long this is my game with rainy
kife or as they say in Holland rainy
kyuf it's actually a Miss marinus but
nobody says that
and this was an Olmstead Dom in 1989 it
was oh this was that tournament this was
and I thought this was in ingrown again
why can't say no this was an Amsterdam
yeah okay so this was actually one of my
better tournaments there were 26 players
and I was greeted 24th but I ended up
getting a plus score and beating golf in
and the Dutch Olympic team so my rating
went up a lot not as much as fun
Whaley's but I went up a lot okay no I'm
black in this position and my comer may
come in any second I don't know how to
flip the board though so it says board
yeah but come on board to flip for that
I'm not no ctrl F I'm not pushing I
using two hands terrible okay so I'm
black and this looks pretty boring so
you'd have a boring joke I can tell her
if I do this no okay
you didn't hear that did you okay good
so in this position looks pretty boring
but in fact if this pawn was back on d3
it looked pretty symmetrical okay but I
checked meet him and just a few moves
because I was good back in those days
now I lecture to you guys so you see
what happened okay what did happen
alright so my opponent played after rook
e8 hooray rikiei he played Knight g5
like I'm nobody
95 I'm 99 when I was good right you
remember that Spence
okay so 95 attacking my pawn on f7 you
see the bishop on b3 okay
that's what Stannis would call a
duffer's move okay we don't do that word
too much now okay yeah the Duffek
terrible 95 ridiculous okay
so I don't want to what's the word
I spoke English I don't want to
acknowledge his 95 you know like come on
Kipling IG five against me
okay so when your opponent attacks on
the wing
what do you Reese was to counter-attack
so I played so I played d5 damn and that
blocks his Bishop so he's no longer
attacking f7 and he took on d5 I took on
d5
it took the Knights look and if you
remember a couple of games ago I said if
you'll remember my opponent had an
isolated pawn and I gave him the
Smackdown now I have an isolated pawn
but my pieces are active there's no
Queens over here there's no Knight f5 my
bishops protecting f5 and I have a dark
squared Bishop my Bishop up b6 is pretty
strong and his knight on d5 is just
silly Knight f3 leaving his light on g5
he's too proud probably should go back
with his knight now where does this
night go the rest of the game what's
what's the future of this night terrible
so I played the obvious move we'll get
it right this time Spence that's the
obvious move now let's go back to the a
g6 after a 6 what's that oh you meant
you meant pawn here that's age 6 or did
you mean a 6 okay man that's good you
know what you're talking about you all
right so what do you say spends Bishop
g4 now h6 is looking good now if I had
played h6 earlier he would play Knight
takes tonight and if I take back then he
can head back to f3 where he belongs and
I'm like nope you're gonna stay on g5
until I take you ok now he didn't want
me to play h6 and then destroy his pawn
structure or win a piece Fang if it's my
move
I think h6 wins apiece Knight h3 Knight
f3 check terrible so he played the
obvious move
terrible Age 3 right and now most of you
in this class could do an hour class on
this do you know why I get paid by the
hour
okay right Mike comer see he did show up
I flipped the board right before he
showed up right before okay now now yeah
now normally you know the lower weight
of players in this class which is all of
you you take the night because that's
what you guys do instead of maintaining
pins okay don't do that anymore unless
you're playing me and then keep doing it
okay when you're pinning somebody you
don't like just trade all the pieces and
unpin them you keep the pin now he made
a dastardly move to totally eliminate
the pen but mycommerce out up I knew I
would meet my camera at some point in my
life reborn 89 yet yeah you were alive
that yeah you were playing chess no I
knew I would meet my comer and I knew
that my opponent to play this smooth so
color would get all excited so my
opponent played tech Mike Allen would
play this move to g4 okay because he
doesn't want to be pinned but what might
calm or retreat his bishop after that I
don't think so and I was thinking about
him and I realized it's not that his
King is exposed which it is it's that
this Knight is trapped i punishing
Knight g5 if I move my bishop back again
he'll play Knight takes Knight and blue
is Knight back to f3 and he's all safe
so I sacrifice a piece because the
knight on d5 is trapped so obviously I
want to meet him and stuff but after h6
where does his Knight go that'll show
him to play Knight g5 he could play King
g2 he may have even played King g2 this
game was played a thousand years ago I
don't remember all right so he played
Bishop a4 not quite King g2 attacking my
rook and I played rookie 7 maybe he
played King g2 now ah back to c2 so King
G - that looks pretty good
can i play 94 and then he has to play
Knight h3 that doesn't look that bad
just looks terrible
I've seen worse
yeah like kingi - that's better it's
been what's that
queen c8 that's annoying so King G - now
he wants to put his knight on h3 if I
attack it so queen c8 so you can't go to
h3 and if Rick h1 we're then greige
three also what's the threat Bishop c2
what's the threat what's the what's the
problem
yeah but I'm too old for this position
this is looks bad for white I must admit
but it looks better than what he did
although my computer said we did was
best so I don't know I thought it looked
still experiment what he did now he
didn't like rookie 4 and 94 so he played
Bishop c2h6 queen d3 so you know this is
like Barney chess I meet you you make me
et cetera right okay he's gonna meet me
on h7 even though there's not even check
so I take he takes yeah and now it's
equal material now if it's white smooth
he's gonna take on f6 and queen h7 check
and so forth because he's got his Queen
and Bishop lined up looks like an ons
game with himself
it's like he's both sides both sides
meeting okay so I played the obvious
move taking advantage of the fact that
I'm pinning his F pawn
yeah I think I play Queen d6 very good
now if he meets me then I made him first
check and if I remember a game played
today upstairs who were you playing
Spence Julian ya g4 and then Queen to it
same thing same trick yeah
Queen g3 pawn takes is illegal as the
computer won't let me do it
Bishop here and then this and black is
better okay so he doesn't like that so
he played Knight to d4 blocking my
bishop terrible
I played the obvious move well I forgot
what I played I thought I'd play Knight
e4 with that hangs my rook so I probably
played rookie 4 right yeah there we go
it's hard for him to meet me now cuz I
blocked his Queen okay now he's down a
pawn and like all my other examples
which I'm trying to impress upon you all
of my pieces are attacking and he'll
come soon but everything's near his king
and his kingdom to have a lot of pawns
in front of it Bishop takes f6 Queen
takes f3 terrible okay
pinning pinning his own night opening up
his King to everything yeah well he did
fork my rook and Bishop now again this
was when I was good in 1989 so when you
played like this boy did I crush you now
if you plugged in as I'd lose on time
okay
I'd be like Eila pieces are hanging no
yeah but back in this day when I had two
bishops and an extra pawn and my
opponent was mated I would win usually
Queen g5 ignoring all the pieces hanging
but lining up my queen with his King
which piece are you willing to take the
bishop that's better than the Queen
looks bad I don't see a mate but there
has to be like he takes the bishop what
do I do
rook should I play rook e8 here because
I've been teaching you guys to do that
now I'm threatening I'm not hanging me
probably or something I knew I shouldn't
do anything
let's see Queen h4 was good
rook g2 which move is best
or maybe I shouldn't take on g4 maybe I
should play rook e8 yeah now my other
works playing in the game so I'm gonna
meet him every move Bishop d1 x glam
know what what aren't I doing yeah this
guy here's a little fishy he's not he's
not defending so well Queen f5 for
example and now if King F Tzu this is
made and if King H something this is
made so probably I would have played
rook e8 cuz I used to see stuff okay my
opponent played f4 very suspicious rook
takes f4 allowing the check that doesn't
do anything I just move my king and his
king is open season if you ever checks
me Ani one Bishop is a check and
responds like on TV so for example if
check what you didn't do
and check and check then I play check
pray and then my next one's gonna be
really good
does anybody see me the one here I'll
bet you don't I'll bet most of you don't
maiden one there's no maintenance no
wonder you don't see it well I didn't
see Bishop h7 rook takes Queen check
which I thought was mate but I missed
the obvious Bishop h7 with equality well
more equality for one side than the
other
okay so he played queen g3 because
there's one discover checks to happen
bishop c7 finding new avenues to win his
queen and unfortunately he resigned
because man I really wanted to keep
going so that was back in the day when I
could actually attack well that was in
that was in fight Kansai that wasn't
alright I'm not sure I believe that
I will do investigation of where that
game was plagues I thought it was played
some another tournament
no I probably was planning overall
terrible okay so now I hope you know how
to attack but unless you're playing me
then play like I do now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]